so today I'm going to talk about
susceptibility to the corona virus and
other viruses in general of course right
now in the news there are freaking
people out about this virus all sorts of
speculating headlines putting people in
fear and worried and I just want to give
my disclaimer nothing said in this video
is meant to treat or cure this virus
this is purely based on my opinion and
there is some research done below I'm
not gonna try to sell you a vitamin or
any cure at all that being said let's
dive into this very interesting topic
now did you realize that when someone
sneezes about 20,000 little droplets
containing viruses are projected through
the air and that is the mode of
transportation for a virus a virus does
not have wings it doesn't have legs it
has to be propelled in the air it has to
be contacted and put on your body
surface and somehow invade the body and
certain viruses have targets for certain
tissues so if you can vision the virus
like a tennis ball with these little
spikes and these spikes have affinity
for different tissues depending on what
virus it is the corona virus has
affinity for the lungs okay so it's
gonna go in the lungs and do its purpose
now the Latin word for virus means
poison
now viruses are everywhere these
biological entities are more abundant
than any other entity on this planet
just one liter of seawater contains over
a hundred billion viruses so it really
has to do with are you susceptible to
the virus now the purpose of a virus is
to deliver its DNA or RNA into the host
cell your cell to be copied so it can
actually continue now DNA and RNA are
just genetic material so viruses can't
do anything without the host without you
so they're not really alive they're not
really dead they have the potential of
acting like they're alive and creating a
lot of damage
so if we take a look at your cell right
here okay and the virus and this is
definitely not in the right proportion
cuz viruses are very very very tiny
certain viruses are like forty four
times smaller than bacteria and they go
through five stages first one is they
attach to your cell wall now realize
that your immune system is looking for
these guys and they're trying to kill it
so if you're susceptible to a virus it
has a much easier job of attaching and
penetrating this wall right here now the
interesting thing about viruses is some
viruses have this envelope around them
that they take from your cell membrane
cover themselves they actually steal it
and they hide so they go underneath the
radar so your immune system cannot find
them so they attach it penetrate and
then they go into the center part which
is the nucleus you see they don't have
any thing that can read this program
let's envision you have this little CD
okay this little round disc and you're
trying to listen to music you're not
going to be able to listen to music
without some type of CD player right you
need something to read it well the virus
does not have a reader it uses your
reader all it has is the CD or the DNA
and it's definitely not gonna be playing
music it just wants to replicate okay
like a copy machine so what it does is
it penetrates it hits a nucleus it
hijacks your copy machine the duplicator
and when it does that it starts to
reproduce at a very fast rate and this
prevents your own body from using that
machine so your own body can now not
replicate anymore so that's not good so
now we have the replicating stage and
then the assemble stage so they're going
to take different things modify their
structure so then they can come out of
the cell and hide from your own immune
system that's what they're going to try
to do so they're gonna be released and
when they get released the cell usually
dies now some viruses actually go
dormant okay
so that's called latent so they just
pretty much hang out and do nothing and
they wait and they wait and they wait
into you're older until you're weakened
until you're nutritionally deficient
until you're stressed and then they come
out and this is why so many people get
virus outbreaks during stress dates
because these viruses are dormant
another interesting thing about certain
viruses is they can activate glycolysis
this is the release of sugar interesting
I'm going to come back to that in a
little bit but I do want to mention this
one point in a study that I read which
I'm going to put a link down below when
you decrease glucose metabolism it
weakens the influenza virus in
laboratory tests now that's very
interesting
all right susceptibility okay there are
several factors that make you
susceptible or vulnerable to viruses in
general age now here's the thing there's
nothing you can do about getting older
so you know let's cross it out right now
let's not talk about that because
there's nothing you can do nutrients
nutrient deficiencies there's a huge
connection between nutritional
deficiencies and the health of the
immune system and the susceptibility for
viruses but there's not a lot of focus
on this one area right here and there's
not a lot of research there's some I put
it down below well we'll talk about this
in a second genetics well you can't do
much about you genes you can do a lot
about the epigenetics which involves
your environment stress nutrition what
you eat but you're given certain genes
okay so we're not going to talk about
that all right number four you're the
health of your immune system if your
immune system is weak you're more
vulnerable more susceptible to getting
the virus and having it create more
destruction the microflora in your
digestive system also around your body
has a huge influence on your immune
system so when you take antibiotics or
you sterilize the body you greatly
increase the chance of getting
infections so
antibiotics steroids drugs chemotherapy
all break down your immune system and
make you weak so you can't fight these
things off also if you have a
pre-existing chronic disease that makes
you susceptible to getting a virus
number 6 stress I've already talked
about this a little bit but stress
significantly increases risk of
infections and viruses I put some data
down below your adrenal glands are
really the gland that regulates your
stress if we take a look at mice that
had their adrenals extracted all sorts
of problems with the immune system
increasing risk of infections viruses if
we also take a look at another condition
called Addison's that's a condition
where your adrenals are basically shut
down they're not working and you need to
take adrenal hormones you'll see a lack
of killer T cells in this condition
interesting unique killer T cells to
defend against viruses also your risk of
infections the way up so the dream ills
are definitely involved but this is the
area I really want to focus on because
you can influence this right here and
you can also influence these with this
so in other words you can strengthen
your immune system this and this with
this right here now there's two things
that happen when you have certain
nutritional deficiencies number one it
weakens your immune system so it makes
your muses tomb weaker but nutritional
deficiencies also make viruses become
stronger now there's a really
interesting study I put it down below
that talks about viruses are more
virulent in selenium and vitamin E
deficient mice which is actually quite
interesting because you would think if
you starve off this virus with nutrients
it would become weaker but no it doesn't
it kicks in a certain gene that makes it
stronger very similar to when we do
fasting our bodies actually become
stronger at least temporarily but
because because you can't fast for for
too long so certain viruses can go from
a virulent to view
and virulent means able to infect the
host so by taking away their nutrition
they become stronger but it makes us
weaker that's not fair
now let's go to the next section that I
want to just kind of touch on this one
topic on age for a second now if we take
a look at the fatality rate of the
corona virus in this age group right
here 80s and older you see a 14 point 8
percent death rate and let's take a look
at if you're 70 or older it's 8% okay 60
comes way down to three point six
percent death right if you're in your
50s it's only one point three percent
40s 0.4 that's less than a half a
percent chance of dying once you're
infected I mean look at this 30s 20s or
let's say you're in your teens 0.2
percent chance okay
this is extremely low this is really
important to know because if you read
the news they make it sound like
everyone's gonna die okay so that's not
true let's take a look at a couple of
things here's the virus compared to
other viruses there's a hundred and
twenty one thousand cases if we take a
look at the fatality percentage is three
point nine percent okay in 113 countries
if we compare that to Ebola SARS and
MERS look at this
Ebola is 40 percent okay fatality rate
SARS is nine point six percent MERS is
thirty four point four percent so the
corona virus actually has the lowest
fatality rate at least of these four
right here it's just interesting
information because sometimes again the
news distorts things and it makes it
sound like everyone's gonna die when
that's not actually true it really
depends on the strength of the immune
system and how strong you can resist it
alright let's talk about the key
nutrients involved in viruses in general
one vitamin C that's probably the most
important vitamin of all vitamins for
viruses it's so very well known
antiviral nutrient it decreases the time
that you have a cold it decreases the
risk of certain lung infections it can
help decrease the susceptibility of
getting an infection in general and it
also can increase the white blood cell
now china right now is doing a study on
vitamin c in the actual city where the
corona virus originated from they're
giving people 24,000 milligrams of
intravenous vitamin c for seven days
we'll have to see the results on that
but that's actually quite interesting
viruses in general when you're infected
deplete your vitamin c that would make
sense as a strategy because if you can
decrease the vitamin c you can decrease
the white blood cell vitamin c has the
tendency to up regulate normal t killer
cells vitamin c is also necessary to
make interferon and interferon stops
viruses by killing the infected cells so
the cell that's been infected with the
virus and it's closely associated
neighbors so it really will help wipe
out viruses now one of the best ways to
give item and see is through food and
hands down the food that has the most
vitamin C is sauerkraut normally a
person needs between 70 and 90
milligrams of vitamin C today certain
types of sauerkraut can give you up to
700 milligrams per cup so that's a
really good source it's also in bell
peppers it's in leafy green vegetables
and it's in a lot of other foods as well
number two vitamin E very very important
in building up your resistance to
viruses selenium another really
important trace mineral zinc involved in
over 200 enzymes but vital for your
immune system and then of course you
have vitamin D viruses have this
interesting strategy to down regulate
the vitamin D receptor
because apparently somehow it knows that
vitamin D is one of the key modulators
for the immune system it helps control
it and this is probably one of the
reasons why people get sick in the
winter in the flew more than during the
summer because the Sun will give you
vitamin D as far as getting selenium and
zinc you can get that from fish and
seafood vitamin E comes from vegetables
nuts and seeds anyway this is a long
video thanks for hanging in there if you
have not seen my video on how to
strengthen your immune system I put it
up right here check it out